all right this is from the
post-millennial bar stool Sports the
popular sports and pop culture brand has
fired one of its hosts Ben Mintz after
he said the n-word while reciting rap
lyrics on a live stream
Barstool Sports founder Dave Portnoy
made the announcement on Wednesday and
expressed his disappointment with the
decision however the decision was made
by barstool's parent company Penn
entertainment due to concerns that the
incident could jeopardize regulatory
gambling licenses across the country
mints apologize for his actions claiming
that it was an honest mistake and said
that he meant no harm
the slur was uttered during his show
wake up mincy where he was reading the
lyrics to first of the month by Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony
and he was so he was reciting the lyrics
or reading them I don't know
and that's a word that's in the lyrics
but but you can't you you can't in no
context of course do we know can you can
is it okay to utter that word depending
on your skin pigmentation because we
know that this word it's a it's a
magical incantation it's like a curse
that you know you find in an old dusty
book in the attic and you you dust off
the book and you open it and you you
recite you say the words in the book and
it has some kind of like just saying the
words as some sort of magical effect
um that's what this particular word is
we're told that's how it's presented
where you cannot even utter the
syllables
in any context even while quoting
someone you can't say the Act you could
say n word
which which is still conveys it still
communicates the word or you say N word
well everyone immediately knows what you
mean
so what is the the moral distinction
between saying n-word or actually
uttering the Civil syllables themselves
while quoting someone what's the
distinction there isn't one it's totally
arbitrary
um but this is the arbitrary completely
ridiculous rule that has been imposed
and um
and so it was decided that this guy has
to pay the price for it you got it well
oh you said the word
technicality you're out you lose your
livelihood and your job
you know and everything
no one no one can morally justify that
um
or justified in any other grounds but
that's the way it's supposed to be
apparently uh going back to post Malone
says despite Apparent pushback from
Portnoy uh Barstool CEO Erica nardini
and longtime Talent Dan Katz Penn
entertainment made the call to terminate
Vince's employment
an entertainment acquired 36 percent of
bar stool Sports from the chernin group
for 163 million 163 million dollars in
early 2020 and bought the remaining 64
for an additional 388 million in
February 2021.
uh Portnoy said that uh you know this
wasn't up to him he doesn't like it he
then posted a video later addressing
fans who were calling him out as a
sellout and as someone who's
participating in cancel culture and he
responded to that with another video I
think we had that
so I get every Tom Dick and Harry since
this mizzy thing be like press your
cello you're so out hey Prez you sold
out
was the kids say no boy no boy I sold
out you're just figuring that out I
start a company and I sold it the
out made hundreds of millions made
Millions for everybody who grinded in
Milton yeah we sold the out and
that's what you do when you're an
entrepreneur you start this little
company you dream one day you sell the
out so no toy still means this
decision sucks I hate it makes me want
to puke
are we back on well clearly someone in
the control room forgot to turn on
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
encrypts 100 of my online data to
protect it from cyberpunks like the ones
who tried to terrorize my show today
when I use expressvpn my online presence
is anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
try to shut me down couldn't be easier
to set up you just tap one button on
your phone or computer and you're
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices your phone tablet computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you don't let the
cyberpunks who tried to hijack my show
hijack your information visit
expressvpn.com Walsh get three extra
months for you that's exp
ressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh
to learn more
uh
okay well he's he's announcing that he
sold out no no it's it's I've never been
in the position where someone's offered
me uh you know what was it in total
almost 400 or over 400 million dollars
in total um no one's ever offered me
that kind of money for anything that
I've done and so I can imagine it's you
know quite an incentive to take the
offer
um and I don't blame him for taking it
no I don't that in and of itself I
wouldn't call seliana but it does mean
that if you consider bar stool Sports to
be some sort of uh
you know so some some sort of
uh
organization that stands at stands
against cancel culture stands for any
kind of values at all if that's if
that's the the notion you had in your
head well then that notion should be
should a long time ago but especially
now I think you should see it better
it's an entertainment company
and that's fine it does entertainment
I'm not particularly a big I don't
really follow what they do but it's you
know it's entertainment
um
apparently they even they took down
their anti-cancel culture culture
merchandise from their store
sort of admitting that well they can't
really you know they can't claim to be
against cancer culture anymore
and they can't because that is yes from
a financial and profit driven
perspective I can understand why you
would take the money someone offers you
400 plus million dollars you take it I
get that but the moment that you do that
well now you are subject to the whims of
this giant corporation that owns you
and you you can't
you can't stand against cancer culture
anymore
um you can't be relied on to
uphold any kind of value system
whatsoever
because you are owned by them and the
only thing the only thing that the
corporation cares about is the money
so that's what we learned about bar
stool but really something we should
have already known
um
and it is again a decision that nobody
no one can logically or morally defend
you know the idea that there's a that
there's a word
that cannot be uttered under any
circumstance is completely insane
and it is not something that there is no
other word
in the English language or any other
language in existence
that we
have those kinds of rules for
any other there's other words that are
slurs there are words that are that we
would consider vulgarity and profanity
um
and all kinds of words that I don't say
on this show
uh because we try not to use profanity
and vulgarity on the show
um words that I don't think you should
use words that you shouldn't use around
kids and so on all kinds of words like
this
um but there's no other word that we
would say well under no circumstance at
all can it even be uttered even in in
the context of quoting somebody
and certainly there's no other word
where we would say well
judging on your skin pigment if it's
this shade you can't say it at all under
any circumstance but if it's a little
bit of a darker shade then say it all
the time and it's totally fine
so there's no context where it can be
said over here there is no context where
it can't be said over here
and we're going to decide that based on
how dark your skin is
makes no sense I think we all are aware
of that that'll do it for uh this
portion shows move over to members block
you can become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed